Brasil ha retomado el reconocimiento de
los territorios indígenas y demarcó seis
más en los estados de acre alagoas
amazonas
ciara goiás y Río Grande de un sul así
lo anunció el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva en un acto junto a grupos
indígenas en el campamento Tierra Libre
y reafirmó su compromiso con Los nativos
brasileños
no quiero que ninguna tierra indígena
quede sin demarcar durante mi mandato
es un compromiso que asumí y un
compromiso con ustedes desde la campaña
no podemos permitir que vuelva a pasar
lo que pasó en las tierras yanomami en
el estado de roraima esto no puede
volver a pasarle a ningún pueblo
indígena
el gobierno del izquierdista reanudó los
procesos establecidos por la ley que fue
paralizada durante el mandato de Jair
bolsonaro los indígenas han denunciado
la violación de las tierras por parte de
empresas mineras y madereras Lula
repitió el objetivo de deforestación 0 y
dijo que necesitará a los nativos como
Guardianes de la selva tras el anuncio
del presidente los miembros de la
comunidad se mostraron esperanzados de
cara al futuro
en nuestra región tenemos un área que
necesita ser demarcada y ratificada como
muchas otras áreas en Brasil en este
caso vinimos aquí para reforzar que
estas luchas de fundamental porque sin
tierras indígenas no hay vida Nuestro
principal objetivo en este momento es la
demarcación de tierras
esta nueva medida se opone a los deseos
del gobernador de Amazonas Wilton Lima
quien sostiene que esas tierras solo
pueden mantenerse bajo una lógica
financiera
oportunidad si no das oportunidades a
las personas que viven en la selva no
dudes de que utilizarán los recursos del
Bosque para garantizar el sustento de
sus familias así que no se puede hablar
de preservación del medio ambiente con
pobreza sus familias con el nuevo
decreto de Lula más de 550.000 hectáreas
de tierra serán protegidas y se sumarán
a unas 600 reservas indígenas que ya
estaban reconocidas por el estado una
superficie equivalente al 14% del
territorio nacional